what about diet is there I saw you
playing with intermittent fasting you
fast does that help with everything
well the things you played what's been
most beneficial to the your ability to
mentally focus on a thing and just meant
the mental productivity and happiness
you still fast yeah it's so fast but I
do intermittent fasting but really what
it means at the end of the day is I skip
breakfast yeah so I do uh 18 6 roughly
by default when I'm in my steady state
if I'm traveling or doing something else
I will break the rules but in my steady
state I do 18 6 so I eat only from 12 to
6. uh not a hard Rule and I break it
often but that's my default and then um
yeah I've done a bunch of random
experiments for the most part right now
where I've been for the last year and a
half I want to say is I'm um plant-based
or planned forward I heard plant forward
it sounds better exactly I didn't
actually know the differences but it
sounds better in my mind but it just
means I prefer plant-based food and raw
or cooked or I prefer cooked and blunt
paste so plant-based
oh forgive me I don't actually know how
wide the category of planned entails
well this just means that you're not um
and you can flex and uh you just prefer
to eat plants and you know you're not
making you're not trying to influence
other people and if someone is you come
to someone's house party and they serve
you a stake that they're really proud of
you will eat it yes right it's just not
judgment oh that's beautiful I mean
that's
um on the flip side of that but I'm very
sort of flexible have you tried doing
one meal a day uh I have uh accidentally
not consistently but I've accidentally
had that I don't I don't like it I think
it makes me feel uh not good it's too
it's too much too much of a hit yeah and
uh So currently I have about two meals a
day 12 and six I do that non-stop I'm
doing it now I'm doing one meal a day
okay it's interesting it's a interesting
feeling have you ever fasted longer than
a day yeah I've done a bunch of water
fasts because I was curious what happens
uh anything interesting yeah I would say
so I mean you know what's interesting is
that you're hungry for two days and then
starting day three or so you're not
hungry it's like such a weird feeling
because you haven't eaten in a few days
and you're not hungry isn't that weird
it's really one of the many weird things
about human biology is figure something
out it finds finds another source of
energy or something like that or uh
relaxes the system I don't know how yeah
the body is like you're hungry you're
hungry and then it just gives up it's
like okay I guess we're fasting now
there's nothing and then it's just kind
of like focuses on trying to make you
not hungry uh and you know not feel the
the damage of that and uh trying to give
you some space to figure out the food
situation so are you still to this day
most productive uh at night
I would say I am but it is really hard
to maintain my PhD schedule
um especially when I was say working at
Tesla and so on it's a non-starter uh so
but even now like you know people want
to meet for
various events they Society lives in a
certain period of time and you sort of
have to like work so that it's hard to
like do a social thing and then after
that return and do work yeah it's just
really hard
uh that's why I try to do social things
I try not to do too uh too much drinking
so I can return and continue doing work
um but a Tesla is there is there
conversions in Tesla but any any company
is there a convergence towards the
schedule or is there more
is that how humans behave when they
collaborate I need to learn about this
yeah do they try to keep a consistent
schedule you're all awake at the same
time I mean I do try to create a routine
and I try to create a steady state in
which I'm uh comfortable in uh so I have
a morning routine I have a day routine I
try to keep things to a steady state and
um things are predictable and then you
can sort of just like your body just
sort of like sticks to that and if you
try to stress that a little too much it
will create uh you know when you're
traveling and you're dealing with jet
lag you're not able to really Ascend to
you know where you need to go yeah yeah
that's weird as humans with the habits
and stuff uh what are your thoughts on
work-life balance
throughout a human lifetime
so the testing part was known for sort
of pushing people to their limits
in terms of what they're able to do in
terms of what they're uh trying to do in
terms of how much they work all that
kind of stuff yeah I mean I will say
teslaq is a little too much uh bad rep
for this because what's happening is
Tesla is it's a bursty environment uh so
I would say the Baseline uh my only
point of reference is Google where I've
interned three times and I saw what it's
like inside Google and deepmind
um I would say the Baseline is higher
than that but then there's a punctuated
equilibrium where once in a while
there's a fire and uh someone like
people work really hard and so that it's
spiky and bursty and then all the
stories get collected about the bursts
and then it gives the appearance of like
total insanity but actually it's just a
bit more intense environment and there
are fires and Sprints and so I think uh
you know definitely though I I would say
um it's a more intense environment than
something you would get it but you in
your person forget all that just in your
own personal life what do you think
about
the happiness of a human being a
brilliant person like yourself
about finding a balance between work and
life or is it such a thing not a good
thought experiment
yeah I think I think balance is good but
I also love to have Sprints that are out
of distribution and that's what I think
I've been pretty uh creative and
um as well Sprints out of distribution
means that most of the time
you you have a yeah quote-unquote
balance I have balance most of the time
I like being obsessed with something
once in a while once in a while is what
once a week once a month once a year
yeah probably like say once a month or
something yeah and that's when we get a
new GitHub repo per month yeah that's
when you like really care about a
problem it must exist this will be
awesome you're obsessed with it and now
you can't just do it on that day you
need to pay the fixed cost of getting
into the groove and then you need to
stay there for a while and then Society
will come and they will try to mess with
you and they will try to distract you
yeah yeah the worst thing is like a
person who's like I just need five
minutes of your time yeah this is the
cost of that is not five minutes and
Society needs to change how it thinks
about just five minutes of your time
right it's never it's never just one
minute it's just 30 it's just a quick
what's the big deal why are you being so
yeah no